foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to use the group bike
loss in SQL but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple Technologies if you're a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn now without further
Ado let's get started with our one point
agenda that is how to use the group by
clause in SQL now before we execute the
actual code let's take a quick peek on
the syntax that we will be using today
now the syntax is completely similar to
the regular syntax that we usually use
which will have the select keyword
parameters that you want to print in
your table the from keyword and the
table name which you are trying to
access the only difference is you will
have a new keyword that is the group by
keyword and based on a certain parameter
right now we would get back to the
Practical mode that is the MySQL
workmans to understand the practicality
of group by clause in a much better way
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we are on our SQL workbench now
let's get access to our simply on
database there you go now let's quickly
take the look at the tables we have we
have two different tables now let's get
access to our
employee table
now we have all the employee numbers
employee names Department designation
salary Etc right let's say you wanted to
know the average salary of all the
employees right so that would be select
that is the AVG
average function of salary
low set bracket from
employee right
let's execute this
there you go now you have the average
salary of the entire office but what
happens when your manager asks you to
find the average of each and every
Department average salary of the
employees in each and every Department
how would you do that
right every organization has multiple
departments HR development testing etc
etc right now your manager wants the
individual Department's average salary
then you can use this particular clause
which says Group by department so the
entire table will be categorized based
on the Departments and it will be
grouped on the basis of the department
and I'm also using the order by here
which we will discuss in the next
session but to give you a brief
understanding of why we're using order
by let's say your manager asks you to
find the department which has the
highest average salary right then you
will be ordering the tables or ordering
the rows based on the descending order
of the salary now let's quickly execute
this query and see the output there you
go the query got successfully executed
and we have the average salary of each
and every Department choose from over
300 in-demand skills and get access to 1
000 Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
and with that we have come to an end of
this session on how to use Group by
clause in SQL if you have inequities
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we used then do let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here